never tell me the odds that's what I've
been saying my entire life when people
said beat up on your YouTube channel not
to work I go odds don't say it yeah
that's what I do remember that remember
that one time well today we're gonna
highlight and honor some other
impossible odds here for example we were
seconds away from oh my god
losing our home to California fire thank
you to all the firefighters that saved
our community Jesus that's right on the
border fire be like I just hill can't do
it man when your boss had been working
there forever
what is this subway what is happening
whoa
that man is gonna become a sandwich
kicker one day trust me Oh
holy moly Katka Roni Pony she says
Christ man only realized he was sat in
front of me halfway through the game
[Laughter]
this is a dick move come on whoa 69 with
696 oh this is the most epic moment
recorded in history becoming number one
subscribing though this is it for me
this is a imagine if all their shirts in
69 as well I'd be flipping losing it
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's sweet I like this this I like
full heart I fill my heart not cracking
healing okay what do we got putting some
cheese on my burger bruh that man
deserves a Nobel price and you know we
come on that's not that hard of a shot
I've seen dude perfect through that shot
at least 50 times cringe downvote small
peepee yes I can dictate small peepee on
other websites thank you very much
imaginative life always was like this
yeah people always say society or
whatever this is what I want this is
what I really want
Milan convenience is to securing
themselves that's all I want curing old
problems in the world no thank you
not interested making things I dropped
fall back into my hands absolutely yes
yes yes yes oh hell yeah I'm not gonna
lie I think the Hat was more impressive
props to the Hat man if you're watching
let me let me know we might bring you
around for a member of you or something
all right
Eagles player Clive said perfect time in
order to accidentally catch the ball
funny damn see this is what I want
imagine it's like what's that guy Ned oh
god what is it called in English Donald
Duck is it Donald Locke the comic book
his cousin skill his only skill is that
he has insane luck that's all I want
luck ten
basically luck hundred that's always
what I go for in those stupid games cuz
that's all I want
calculated way to avoid a ticket
did he try them off did he do that on
purpose
some GTH pub GStreamer randomly shoots
one sniper bullet assess a bug
accidentally kill enemy 400 meters away
oh it sets the meters now chief says I
don't know I've seen a few nights tops
in Call of Duty way more impressive
cringe why am i laughing that's awful
but also very funny cats that cat must
think he's amazing I have superpowers
my god oh well better clean myself the
catch this kid made was amazing that was
not amazing without one okay now I have
it what the hell is this is that it oh
my dog that's Jesus pigeon as a pigeon
pee poop pigeon poop or trace it's that
is amazing Jesus Christ literally I
believe all religions now all of them
simultaneously holy cow dude I use the
tree to build the tree oh yeah don't hit
me whatever this is baseball from this
angle I'm like oh God isn't oh oh
[Laughter]
see I wouldn't even be impressed cuz I
do this all the time
watch wash watch you see my bottle flip
video okay this is not a coincidence
this is not a coincidence that matrix is
trying to communicate with this Red
Cross team accidentally captures meteor
whoa they didn't even see it
holy cow dude that's so cool not
impressed not impressed not impressed
was that it not impressed on about you
guys but I was not impressed not
impressed not impressed I can I've done
that in many times in video games not
impressed still not impressed
bacteria be like okay I'm used mildly
amused you win whoa okay volleyball I've
seen enough high Q to know if I should
be impressed that was a terrible smash
the setter did not set that up properly
she was barely over the net the blockers
should have done a simple OneTouch
crunch I'm gonna steal the camera
see what luck is important this would
never happen to me 10 luck Lefou listen
all right let's see if we can impress me
yesterday oh yeah that's the way to do
it
Oh No still calculated calculated oh my
god
the thumbs-up saver of lives yes the
power of gods
this is what I want this is the super
powers I want goddamn eight it's not
fair I have no talent
I feel like next time we have to do when
people just mess up or something to
contrast this because this is not a good
reflection of the world all right let's
see it says wait for it not impressed
not impressed see this is why you need
ten luck I bet he got women later yeah
yeah he got women what is this move for
tonight Dame's got a never for tonight
dance told you kids aren't impressive we
skip not impressive not impressed
that's funny presently well also
something
decimal doesn't count but boy does they
do what a beta what a loser
whoa it even went this direction I want
that that could be me
I can't backflip I can't do anything I
never felt so insufficient watching this
I'm now the Rubik's Cube okay
unimpressed okay that's way more
impressive the confucian nice noise dog
in for the way poor dog it's a dog okay
it's a dog okay need to check comments
okay dog fine I read it set the fire
truck fire Oh God oh my god
why is that funny when real life gets
subtitles what twice that's impressive
whoever packed that though come on what
the hell you got to go on the news for
it yes it was the happiest day of my
life not only did it bounce once but it
bounced twice that's unheard of just
wondering whether you remember the Dobby
max in 1967 they're good it's an FA Cup
fifth round and it was shown on a big
screen I'm fearless
tell me Lawrence somebody nice to meet
you what would you remember about it
it's great game yeah score the winner I
don't know why I enjoy these more I
don't know why more wholesome dude
that's a wizard right there so you made
fun of even forgetting it [ __ ] in the
face what are the odds that's insane
why am I so depressed by that that's
amazing stop yes now that's comedy
I don't care what anyone says that is
the funniest thing except the 69 shirt
from earlier that was almost as funny
whoa wear safety glasses kids she says
holy moly I didn't know those things
were sharp
isn't that just sandpaper Jesus Oh God
the anxiety this gives me I don't like
it Oh rocket League hell yeah let's get
it are they gonna bounce that in Tim
what's happening
he's afk yeah it would have gone in
anyway but yeah that's funny
[Laughter]
amazing golf shot I'm down for it did it
go straight in yeah Wow
on the flag Wow incredible not impressed
a man taps another man's shoulder not
knowing that would save his life oh oh
that's that's God right there what the
hell oh my god that gave me shivers sued
holy cow he might have still lived but
still that's incredible I can't watch
this anywhere it's too much anxiety
thank you for watching never tell me the
odds now remember kids always say not
the odds thank you for watching
subscribe and all that epicness and I
see you guys tomorrow it's time to race
what was once forgotten
what creatures fought spells and put
troops awaits hope tea is coming to
Nintendo's wait and remember it has a
very big TV pre-order promotion heavy
de mes checkbook birthday girl of Angela
[Music]